That's the moment when Andy came back to
make his movie.
>> Hello.
>> What happened after was out of my
control? Andy felt it was necessary to
stay in the character.
>> He's exactly the way Andy was.
>> It's totally surreal.
>> When I heard I had the part,
>> please welcome Tim Carrie.
>> It's as if I went into a fugue state.
>> Me [music] and the
>> and Hyde showed up.
>> That story is just such a part of
Christmas. So yeah, it was incredibly
important [music] not to screw it up.
>> What happened after was out of my
control.
>> It was not me. I was not making choices
based on what Jim does.
>> Here's your motivation.
>> He felt it was [music] necessary for him
to stay in the character. We'll never
watch. Just keep it kind of loosey
goosey.
>> At some point he tapped me on the
shoulder and said, "Sit down. I'll be
doing my movie." Action.
The attitude was already there. And when
you put that makeup on, there's no
choice. That nose, the jowls.
Universal, they didn't want the footage
we took behind the scenes to surface so
that people wouldn't [music] think I was
an You're going to have people
that are going to sue this production
for mental stress.
[screaming]
>> Yeah. There's feelings of guilt,
feelings like, damn, I lost control
again
to him. When the movie was over, I
couldn't remember who I was anymore.
>> I'm the Grinch. I'm the Grinch. [music]
>> So, you step through the door not
knowing what's on the other side. What's
on the other side is everything.
>> Definitely definitely an important
moment in the process where I found
myself uh subjugating Jim Carrey for
Andy Kaufman and Tony Clifton. And then
uh and then at the end of it looking for
Jim Carrey again and having trouble
finding him. And at a certain point, I I
realized, hey, wait a second. You know,
if it's so easy to lose Jim Carrey, who
the hell is Jim Carrey?
>> Before I started work, [music] I went
over to Christ Cathedral and uh I I sat
by his grave and I prayed a rosary with
him. I finished praying with him.
I said, "Lonnie, I want to honor you
with this film,
and I [music] really want to um to to to
bring justice and and you know, the
testament to the gifts of God's grace
and and [music] powers that you you
know, displayed while you were on this
earth. And so,
if this is a good idea that I do this
film,
have somebody give me a sign. Give me a
sign. Have God give me a sign." And the
minute the words left my mouth
behind me there was a door open to the
cathedral and this giant cord rang out
for about 5 seconds.
So I heard that and I was like
okay thanks for that. You
channel the spirit of Malcolm because I
remember one specific time where, you
know, we went to Malcolm's speeches and
once you finished with the text, you
kept on going.
>> Right. Right. Right.
>> And we we I say cut. [laughter]
>> We kept
>> kept loading the camera.
>> We kept loading the camera.
>> And there were many times in that film
where we all had to pinch oursel because
we thought we saw the reincarnation
right
>> of Malcolm. It wasn't about
impersonation. You're trying to capture
the spirit. the spirit and just trying
to, you know, act as well. I'm going to
look like him and that. But that's
that's just surface stuff.
>> Basically, what I did was got on my
knees
and sort of communicated with the
spirits and when I came out, I was in
charge.
>> Powerful scene.
>> Powerful scene. It It was I couldn't
have acted that. I couldn't have written
that down and made a decision to play
that. There was a a particularly
profound moment where I went to um
Chattanooga, Tennessee, which is where
Desmond eventually retired and passed
away. And I went onto his old property
um and went into his his old wood
woodshed and handled his tools and
walked around the lake that he would
walk [music] around. And it was I spent
a day there just kind of praying and and
and asking like just guide me through
this. If you can hear me, tell me like
tell me tell me what to do. Tell me how
to move, tell me how to speak, tell me
how to behave, and I'll do whatever you
say. So that there was some there there
was a a strange mysterious spirituality
going on around the the making of this
film.
>> I think he wasn't a talker, Desmond. And
Andrew is able to convey very much
without the need [music] of dialogue as
an actor. I mean, you can just see it
through his eyes and stuff. It's all
going on.
So I mean, I his talents, I think I
think very talented just suited this
character. And then I wasn't
disappointed at all.
managed to inhabit Desmond or Desmond
inhabited him. I'm not sure which. I
think there was some both going on.
>> Sasha is my alter ego.
[music]
>> I'm really kind of shy and not really
shy, but more reserved and um nothing
like Sasha. She can do things that I
cannot do when I'm in rehearsal. I mean,
I can try, [music] but then it just
doesn't happen. I can sing notes and
sing strong and [music] do all these
things that when I'm just by myself I
can't do.
>> I try to allow the spirit of the
character to live through me. So I just
try to encompass and allow myself I'm
almost the vehicle to channel [music]
the spirit of the character through. My
one experience with Heath um on the film
was our scene [music] together in the
hospital bed which is really my only
scene with him and it was um I was in
the hospital bed that day and I thought
well I don't really have any lines what
am I going to do and I had no idea what
was going to happen and so I was got in
the bed and they [music] were lighting
and Chris was walking around and doing
things and then Heath came around and
Heath was always in character so he
would come around and you know be
[music] talking to himself in the corner
like this and then all of a sudden my
hand would go up like this and he cap
caught my hand. So we just [music] went
through this organic process of
developing this scene which was really
nothing. And then he puts his hand
[music] on my shoulder and he goes,
"That's what acting's all about."
>> I am all about mediums. I'm so obsessed.
Anyone that knows me knows I love
connecting to the spirit world. So yeah,
if he can tell me anything about my
psoriasis and how to fix it, I'm down to
see what happens. [music] I don't know
much about you. Are you a real medium?
>> Yeah, I'm the medical medium. Been doing
this forever. Just going through every
organ looking for the problem. With you,
it's definitely the liver. You have
really high [music] deposits of copper.
I know it probably sounds so
far-fetched, right?
>> No, I believe in it.
>> Heart looks good.
>> And then [music] we launched into the
first take and two voices came out of
you. Do you remember this? two voices
[music] and they were they were
simultaneous words but they were two
levels of sound. And you [music] said
well Cheryl I'm I'm many different
people.
I said no Jack you're channeling.
Monroe attributed her ability to affect
the public to other entities that would
inhabit her and take her over. She was
known for entering into deep transes
before each scene. One of Monroe's close
personal psychics recalled how she would
draw attention from the spirit world
asking for their guidance.
>> Been told that um all actors really hail
from the early medicine men and the the
shamans in the villages pre-Christianity
where they would put on masks and and
act out and and really what they were
probably pretty crazy.
>> In in this movie, you uh literally are
fighting an inner demon, this this hell
beast that lives within you. And I'm
kind of curious. It looks like it takes
a lot of energy just to be able to bring
that out physically performing it. What
was it like kind of working yourself up
to that energy level to kind of have
this fire burning inside of you?
>> Well, what happens is when you make a
decision to use the outside to work in,
not only does it give you a kind of
power, not unlike a child on Halloween,
it also instills fear in your co-stars
and the people around you. when you see
that in their eyes and then then you
don't have to act cuz you suddenly get
power from their fear. So, what I would
do is I'd put on AfroCaribbean [music]
paint, like a white and black paint, and
black out my eyes so I look like this
sort of AfroCaribbean voodoo icon, and
then I would sew in bits of u Egyptian
artifacts that were thousands of years
old into my costume and gather some onyx
or termine or something that was meant
to have vibrations. And who knows if it
works or doesn't, but for me it was an
idea of like trying to stimulate my my
mind or trick my mind into believing I
was this this character from another
dimension. And I would walk on the set
and then wouldn't speak to anybody,
wouldn't say a word. So I projected this
aura of horror which created fear in my
fellow actors which then inspired me to
believe I really was this character.
>> And the same thing too if you in the
mythology, if you could sell your soul
to the devil, this could happen to you.
I think that was the
>> well in a in an interesting way uh
ghostriter is more real if you go for
that sort of thing [music] in that he
deals between the spiritual and the
material and if you have a open mind
anything is possible. I think [music]
just being in that kind of uh that mind
state that that that real unapologetic,
you know, just just real like, you know,
whatever all the time
>> kind of kept it caught up with me and
and like I I got a little, you know, a
little depressed. It was tough for me
for a minute, you know, just readjusting
to being around
>> the people that care about me, getting
that love that I shut out for a long
time. Like I shut out love. I didn't
want love and affection, you I wanted to
be in this [music] lonely place as long
as I could in order to kind of capture
the essence of what Eric, you know,
Stevens was, what Killilmonger was. So
when when we wrapped the film, you know,
I'm like in my mind, I was like, "Okay,
cool. Go back to, you know, regular
life. Get back to LA and be cool." But
it was a little tough for me at first to
kind of like accept.
>> It was hard just to lay him down and be
done with it.
>> Yeah.
>> How did it take you a while?
>> It took me It took me, you know, I mean,
I don't really know exactly when I came
out of it, but you know, I went went to
therapy, you know what I'm saying? I I
started talking to people, started
unpacking a little bit.
>> I prayed a lot to Oscar during this. You
know, I asked for his guidance to be
around me like shooting this film. So, I
mean, I I can't I can't give any give
any credit to anybody but Oscar. And um
>> you know, I would I would pray to him,
you know, I would I would channel his
energy. I would just ask to be around.
It's that weird eerie feeling, but it
was a good feeling. You know, I don't
think I could have done it without him
>> being there.
>> Him. Oscar.
>> Oscar.
>> The energy of Oscar.
>> The energy of Oscar. His presence for
sure.
>> Yeah. You know, I've learned a lot from
my wife over the years. She's so about
the power of intention, you know, and
believing things that are really going
to happen. So, she put together a little
altar for me that I could bring with
pictures of my kids. And I have these
little special stones and healing stones
and protection stones. And she has me
wear a necklace and take these drops she
makes. And I say all these mantras.
She said, "You're lucky you married a
witch. I'm just a good witch."
[laughter]
She died at 17 and she had just had my
mother. Uh she was found with her hands
tied behind her back hung in the
basement.
>> Wow. So [music] let's see
my symbol for alone. Alone alone.
>> Like she was super felt super alone.
>> Like this is coming through in a way of
like I plan like I [music] don't want to
be with grandpa. This is a message I
want to kind of deliver and it's
something that they do frequently say
but it comes through extra in [music]
this case. She does not want her death
to be how we remember her when it comes
to like her life. And just recently
there was a conversation that was had
she wasn't [music] able to have closure
or really convey her feelings to the
full extent. And the feeling is
basically I die without being able to
have a resolve.
>> Yeah.
>> She from her end has released this. She
wants you to know she didn't kill
herself.
>> Okay.
We've always sort of speculated there
there could be like some ghost dance
parties happening around while we're
here.
>> There's a presence of a woman that comes
through pretty strongly. And it's like
very much in here for some reason and
like up there. So if you see someone out
of the corner of your eye, don't worry.
>> It's all good.
>> Is it all good friendly?
>> It's all good. Friendly, but connect to
the house in some way and it's just very
like kitchen oriented and up up the
stairwell.
Regard not them that have familiar
spirits, neither seek after wizards to
be defiled by them. I am the Lord your
God.
There shall not be found among you
anyone that maketh his son or his
daughter to pass through the fire, or
that useth divination, or an observer of
times, or an enchanter, or a witch, or a
charmer, or a consulter with familiar
spirits, or a wizard, or a necromancer.
For all that do these things are an
abomination unto the Lord. And because
of these abominations,
the Lord thy God doth drive them out
from before thee.